what we're looking at is a very
interesting and disturbing Crackdown on
Free Speech that's happening across the
English speaking world it's happening in
the UK in the United States Canada New
Zealand Australia it's also happening in
Brazil very aggressively but we also see
the European Union preparing to impose
new regulations on speech in all these
cases they're offering seemingly benign
or benevolent reasons for this but these
are very serious measures that are being
put in place that are aimed at censoring
people online and it comes in the
context of Revelations that both the
United States the UK and many of these
other countries have in fact been
pressuring social media companies to
censor disfavored views and even
de-platform disfavored users and so it's
really one of the most significant
threats to freedom of speech certainly
since the creation of the internet and
perhaps over the last hundred years